welcome to this video playing anti-drone
isn't he playing like this no okay
thought you place the Queen porn stuff
that you keep forgetting who that is
okay sharp sharp line I don't know that
line yet so I'm basically have to invent
stuff now I know some ideas I know that
after a form black and can return a pawn
I think it is with e6e 6a be five and
then might be six something like that I
believe is right but I'm really no
expert this is an opening experiment
yeah you can play Bishop d7 but then II
sex is always tricky move to meet that
pawn sacrifice I wonder if Bishop b4 as
a move it's probably not so terrible and
then then back to these things and maybe
doesn't look too bad how interesting not
too shifty to vivo make some sense
certainly and I can also go Bishop e7
now under sniper six I come on let's go
night basics now only think that you can
really ask yourself for special before
helping anyway hmm really
okay I think he wants to go Queens you
for but I was a cheek be five crew kade
Queen 88 queen i have this Queen a1
counter-attack ideas
ap Wicked Queen 88 Queen g7 rook f8
always quick enough we should be true
Queen a 1 wow that's interesting I am
not sure if it is in any way come on
let's do it maybe it's just completely
completely wacky no it's not even trying
it stop trying to take ok so so 95 then
Queen the Queen a 1 I mean the worse
they can take them I will always have
those pawns so that that is like that is
that the those pawns I will always have
them
oh i see i have a problem here bishop if
he castles bishops III Queen g7 rookie
evade bishop age six is a problem and
that's a real problem
yeah what a shame that's really really
bad
I shoot pool that's bad that's really
bad I cannot do this bishops III Queen
g7 rookie I made bishop age 60 f no move
I have no move Wow okay
yeah this has to be bad but the other
line was just losing i mean like losing
no okay it's equal material maybe I can
somehow get my cream back and play this
stuff 55 queen bee five
my development is not exactly great
no that Mouse sleepy a great Queen B 6
of course jack hey I have everybody sees
that I know okay black resign man hmm
Queen B 6 I don't know I said so bad
probably it is a my development is just
just too bad but he still has to win
this now instead of giving the Queen
away yeah so let's have a look there
maybe I was just a bit too creative
there oops so Queen d5 greens you form
yeah probably probably that's not really
working I found this idea interesting it
takes and of course you can question if
I have to go be sure before I mean I
know that this is a normal normal line
where black is supposed to be completely
fine but ok let's have a look Queenie
for their queen g4 yeah this I was
thinking my idea was like this rook
evade and i was thinkin like we should
be too and queen a one that was my idea
but what I always what I didn't see us
said here he has this move and this is
winning for white and this is
essentially what what was what's
happened in the game I went I went to a
one he canceled and now I recognize that
bishops III is not working and if that
is not working I really have no move I
think this was maybe relatively
relatively best but yeah now this is
probably yeah that's probably a bit too
strong he takes the fire forever wasn't
move yeah why didn't I do that I didn't
actually recognize that this is covered
it's not that great actually for what
now okay I was tricky anyway not so with
no time whatsoever still I don't have to
have to give him the Queen Bishop takes
before winning but of course that's the
Queen ya doing a mall step is always
awkward but well the engine says Queen B
6 and then rooks you wanted with the
wind yeah i still have big problems
moving the pieces like you might do this
he goes with a 14 this now it was just
an opening disaster okay well thanks for
watching